[Musique] Les
femmes Taketa Les femmes Giavotella sont
beaucoup plus profondes pour Barney Je vois clairement que nous
n'avons tous pas de chemin
pour Adhamiya  nativité Allah
Muhammad Allah Poorman aurait une
écurie c'est une petite effets visuels un
gouvernemental dit parti mezzo en petite
fille chauffée Sarah
Sessa assise dans des responsabilités normales
juste une merde capable rouillée d'
accord idiot pas une chance
malheureux besoin de transformer mon entreprise
[Musique]
avez-vous  j'ai déjà été nounou c'est ma
première côtelette vivante eh bien j'espère que tu sais
ce que tu fais les enfants sont très
spéciaux Kate
utilise tes amis doivent adorer ça ici je
n'ai pas d'amis tu n'as pas d'amis oui
eh bien tu en as un maintenant rien qu'elle avait
souffrir ce n'est pas si simple
tu ne devrais pas être ici ce qui est arrivé
à ta dernière nounou comme je dirais que tu
dois prendre en charge Hécate je sais ce que
tu as peur de garder les lumières allumées
ne te gardera pas en sécurité peux-tu  s'il te plait arrête
je n'y vais pas de toute façon  ici
promesse promesse croix mon coeur
descend
tout le monde meurt des kilomètres as tu vu
[Musique]
arrête les
mauvais rêves
toi